mais à mon âge c'est quoi il risque de
me retrouver à l'hôpital tout nouveau se
retrouver à l'hôpital la question ce pas
seulement de protéger par mot si les
autres en août 2021 pour encourager sa
population à se vacciner le ministère de
la santé en france a créé un spot tv qui
conclut comme suit on peut débattre de
tout sauf des chiffres aujourd'hui en
france huit personnes sur dix
hospitalisées à cause du coc vide ne
sont pas vaccinés tous vaccinés tous
protégés de la même façon en suisse le
conseiller d'état valaisan matthias
reynard signa le fait que 90% des
hospitalisés ne sont pas vaccinés ces
statistiques sont ainsi utilisés pour
insister sur l'importance et
l'efficacité de la vaccination et
j'imagine que beaucoup de pros vax parmi
vous l'aurais retweet et si vous étiez
sur twitter et si vous avez vu ce
chiffre cependant aujourd'hui je vais
essayer de vous convaincre que ce genre
de statistiques est en fait très
problématique à partager non pas parce
qu'elle est erronée mais parce qu'elle
est en fait trompeuses en particulier
elle ne permet pas du tout de conclure
directement à l'efficacité du vaccin et
donc à l'importance de se faire vacciner
en tout cas pas tout seul pis encore
dans les mois à venir surtout en france
où la couverture vaccinale grandi la
mise en avant de telles statistiques
même probablement conduire à un chaos
informationnel cette même statistique
pourrait bientôt donner l'impression que
se vacciner est dangereux pour la santé
ce qui va ensuite probablement conduire
un chaos informationnelle et à la proche
des élections avec de telles habitudes
on risque fort d'assister à la
popularité de mouvement très mal
informée au triomphe des campagnes de
désinformation et potentiellement même à
des révoltes violentes dangereuse
si vous avez suivi cette série vous
m'avez entendue répéter les créations
suivante la vraisemblance des données
n'est pas la crédence de la théorie ou
dit autrement la probabilité de donner
des sachants une théorie t n'est en
général pas du tout est égal à la
probabilité inverse de la théorie t
sachant les données t de façon plus
générale pour toutes variable a et b la
probabilité de haas à chambé n'est pas
égal à la probabilité inverse de b
sachant arts et dans le cas des vaccinés
hospitalisé cette distinction est
absolument critique à avoir en tête en
effet notamment dans un pays où le taux
de vaccination est très élevé comme
c'est de plus en plus le cas en france
il faut en fait s'attendre à ce que la
probabilité d'être vaccinés sachant
qu'on est hospitalisé soit élevé alors
que la probabilité inverse d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on est vacciné
restera faible ou dit autrement ce qu'il
va probablement finir par arriver c'est
que la plupart des vaccinés ne seront
jamais hospitalisé quand bien même la
plupart des hospitalisés seront vaccinés
et le jour où ça va arriver à y
aller ça va être la cacophonie avec des
arguments moisi 2 partout le tout appuyé
par des statistiques parfaitement
factuelle mais trompeuse surtout avec
les élections présidentielles et des
candidats qui vont constamment cherché à
plaire à leur électorat d'ailleurs de
tels chiffres ont déjà été constatés
dans le cas d'israël où le taux de
vaccination est un 90 % chez les
personnes âgées et où la majorité des
hospitalisés sont des personnes
vaccinées et oui en israël six
hospitalisés sur dix sont vaccinés mais
clairement ce taux de vaccinés parmi les
hospitaliser d'un très mauvais chiffres
à communiquer car il est si facile de
mal interprété et malheureusement les
sceptiques de l'efficacité vaccinale où
les campagnes de désinformation qui
veulent affaiblir un pays ennemi vont
probablement se faire une joie de
relayer massivement de telles
statistiques or comme on va le voir très
bonne caisse ou des banshee et ses
statistiques de vaccinés parmi les
hospitalisés c'est déjà horriblement
difficile même auprès de gens assez à
l'aise en maths et suffisamment en mode
explorateurs pour réfléchir calmement
surtout que dans les mois à venir il n'y
aura pas uniquement cette statistique à
des bunkers tellement de chiffres
circulent venant de tellement de pays au
contexte différent quand thierry piquant
à gauche et à droite on peut trouver
toutes sortes de statistiques qu'il
suggère tout et son contraire
en exploitant typiquement la confusion
omniprésente entre une probabilités
conditionnelles p2a sachant b et nos
probabilités inverse p2b sachant à quand
on sait que même des scientifiques et
même des statisticiens ont un mal fou à
distinguer la probabilité de à sa jambe
et de la probabilité de baie saint jean
à on est vraiment mal barré eh oui pour
rappel ce sophisme et même au coeur de
la méthode scientifique par p valliot et
bien sûr dans les mois à venir on risque
aussi d'assister à des interviews de
gens qui ne voulaient pas être vaccinés
mais qui à cause des circonstances se
sont sentis contraints d'être vacciné et
qui ont néanmoins dû être hospitalisés
avec possiblement des séquelles à long
terme ces personnes risquent alors fort
de témoigner de l'inutilité des vaccins
probablement avec un esprit
contestataire le tout sur bfm tv ou i
télé et ça ça peut monter en flèche dans
les mois à venir et influencer ensuite
les positionnements politiques et la hi
hi hi hi hi bref comme vous le comprenez
je suis très loin d'être confiant pour
le futur à moins d' effort massif pour
soutenir l'information de qualité sa
production et surtout sa recommandation
la crise est systémique risque de
continuer à avoir des conséquences
dramatiques à la fois sur le plan
médical mais aussi en termes de
géopolitique d'environnement et de
justice sociale
bon c'est bien beau de se de la
mésinformation mais il ne suffit pas de
la noyer pour la combattre si on veut
améliorer le niveau épistémique les
critiques de parvenir à mieux réfléchir
soi même et à aider les autres à mieux
réfléchir et donc pour finir cette vidéo
je vais essayer de vous faire sentir la
raison pour laquelle la probabilité de à
sa jambe est peut-être très différente
de la probabilité inverse de b sachant
art le tout pour que vous ayez davantage
de réflexe de vous demander si une
statistique du genre beaucoup de besson
a est vraiment ce qu'il est pertinent de
constater et de partager je vous propose
de commencer par avoir des exemples en
tête pour essayer de travailler notre
intuition instinctive en particulier
pour cela je vous invite vivement à
revoir l'épisode 21 où on a vu que la
plupart des musulmans ne sont en fait
pas des arabes quand bien même la
plupart des arabes sont effectivement
musulmans en effet il est vrai que
certains arabes ou d'autres religions
certains sont hâtés d'autres sont
catholiques mais ceux ci sont rares
parmi eux arabe la plupart des arabes
sont musulmans néanmoins la plupart des
musulmans ne sont pas arabes et ça c'est
parce qu'il ya énormément de gens en
asie et qu'une fraction certes faible
mais non négligeable d'entre eux sont
musulmans notamment en indonésie en
chine ou en inde gardez bien cet exemple
en tête la plupart des arabes sont
musulmans mais la plupart des musulmans
ne sont pas arabes
et si on se demande pourquoi et bien
c'est pas mal parce qu'il ya énormément
de gens notamment en asie qui ne sont
pas musulmans mais ne sont pas arabes
particuliers il y en a beaucoup plus que
de gens qui sont arabes autre exemple
que je vous propose de garder en tête
qui est un exemple que j'ai mentionnés
dans l'épisode 22 la plupart des prix
nobel aime le chocolat mais la plupart
de ceux qui aiment le chocolat n'ont pas
de prix nobel et si c'est le cas c'est
parce que de façon encore plus massive
il y a énormément de gens qui aiment le
chocolat et non pas de prix nobel
beaucoup plus que de gens qui ont un
prix nobel enfin je vais rajouter un
troisième exemple ultra classique qui
est celui des tests médicaux un parfait
pour des maladies très rares comme en
parle d'ailleurs fait bouilloire veritas
yonne ou encore monsieur fille même si
un test est valide à 99% si la maladie
ne touche qu'une personne sur un million
alors les malades ont presque tous un
test positif mais ceux qui ont un test
positif sont quasiment tous non malades
voilà je vous invite à vraiment méditer
ces exemples en tête car le problème des
hospices il est vacciné est exactement
le même en particulier de la même façon
en israël la plupart des hospitalisés
sont vaccinés mais la quasi-totalité des
vaccinés ne sont pas hospitalisés tout
ça parce qu'il ya énormément de gens qui
sont dax inné et ne sont pas
hospitalisés beaucoup plus que de gens
qui sont hospitalisés et pour bien que
cette distinction entre profiter de haas
a chanté et la probité de bsh en
advienne absolument un réflexe pour
votre intuition instinctive je vous
invite à le rechercher par vous-même
d'autres exemples encore c'est souvent
beaucoup plus efficace pour retenir un
principe si on parvient à trouver
soi-même un exemple marquant qu'illustre
parfaitement
pour les gens un peu plus
vous je vous propose une explication
plus fine de ce phénomène qui fait appel
au curseur de turing ça va vous demander
à un peu plus d'efforts mais si vous
saisissez très bien le curseur de turing
alors vous pourrez résoudre beaucoup
plus de paradoxe apparent qu'avec une
poignée d' exemples représentatifs d'un
cas très précis rappelez-vous le curseur
de turing permet d'appliquer
rigoureusement la formule de base dans
un cas où il n'y a que deux théories à
comparer et là ça tombe bien dans notre
cas on a envie de comparer les cas pas
vaccinés et le cas vacciner pour un
individu donné mettons donc pas vaccinés
et vaccinés à chaque bout d'une droite
la position initiale du curseur
représente ensuite la probabilité qu'un
français tirés au hasard soit vacciné au
fil des mois ce curseur n'a cessé de se
déplacer vers la droite puisque le taux
de vaccination a augmenté et en fait
sachant que fin août par me sens
français il y avait soixante trois
personnes ayant reçu deux doses et 28
n'ayant reçu aucune dose on est même à
un peu plus de 1 bit du côté de la
vaccination ok maintenant essayons
d'estimer la probabilité qu'une personne
soit vacciné sachant qu'elle est
hospitalisé pour cela il faut estimer
comment la donne et la personne est
hospitalisée déplace le curseur de
turing et ça ça dépend de ce que j'ai
appelé le rapport de surprises autrement
dit à quel point devrions nous être
davantage surpris par l'hospitalisation
d'un individu sachant qu'il est vacciné
par opposition à sachant qu'il n'est pas
vaccinée alors je vous épargne les
détails de calcul mais cette question
est en fait directement relié à
l'efficacité du vaccin pour un vaccin
efficace à 89% la surprise de
l'hospitalisation en cas de vaccination
est neuf fois plus grande que la
surprise en cas de non vaccination pour
il ya des subtilités derrière cette
notion d'efficacité vaccinale et on y
reviendra d'ailleurs dans la prochaine
vidéo or un facteur de 9 ça correspond à
un peu plus de 3 bits d'information en
déplaçant le curseur de 3,8 dans la
direction de la théorie qui explique
mieux l'hospitalisation qu'on constate
que a posteriori le curseur de turing
penche deux buts en faveur de la non
vaccination ou dit autrement on s'attend
alors à ce qu'il soit quatre fois plus
probable qu'un hospitalisés soit vacciné
que non vaccinés
ou dit encore autrement sur cinq
hospitalisées 4 qui ne devrait pas être
vaccinés ce qui correspond d'ailleurs
aux chiffres actuellement en france ok
mais notamment suite au passage iter il
faut s'attendre à ce que le taux de
vaccination augmente dans les mois à
venir en france imaginons que désormais
90% des français sont doublement
vaccinés contre 10 % de non vaccinés
désormais à priori avant de savoir si un
individu est hospitalisé le curseur de
turing penche de 3,2 but en faveur de la
vaccination
mais alors à posteriori après le
déplacement de 3,2 beat dû à la donner
l'individu est has put alizés on se
retrouve à 0 autrement dit si 90 % des
français sont doublement vacciner et si
le vaccin est efficace à 90% alors parmi
les hospitalisés il y aura autant de
vacciner que de non vaccinés et alors je
précise quand même que mon analyse ici
est en fait trop simplifié notamment car
elle omet de nombreux facteurs de
confusion comme l'âge de la personne ses
antécédents médicaux et son application
des gestes barrières si les personnes
âgées sont plus vacciner si les
personnels déjà infectés sont vaccine -
et si les vaccinés prennent moins soin
de leurs gestes barrière alors il faut
s'attendre à ce que la plupart des
hospitalisés soit vacciné et ce même si
le vaccin demeure efficace à 90% autant
dire que en fait oui les statistiques
sur les nombre de vaccinés parmi les
explique alizée ça ce débat mais le
problème c'est que pour bien en débattre
il faut connaître un minimum de
statistiques